[Music]
new york city
restaurant capital of the world home to
thousands of restaurants vying to be the
crown jewel of the city
the black pearl just being won
started by two friends as a small
downtown lobster shack they moved to
midtown added a third partner and hoped
to become the premier lobster restaurant
in manhattan
i suggested to brian that we put an ad
in the paper to find uh an investor
since we didn't want to spend any of our
own money ordering two hot lobster rolls
i met greg and thought that he would be
a perfect match gentlemen fish and chips
it was david's concept and um i thought
the concept was really very good and i
thought would make some pretty good
money did we get that 2500 because i'm
about four grand short of payroll the
problem started when we started to run
low on money it became very frustrating
around here brian and greg and i stopped
speaking we would try to communicate by
email text messaging and everybody got
nervous and frustrated this place is a
nightmare for the lack of management we
don't have one voice i just asked brian
he's like yeah well you guys can figure
it out can we always figure it out well
i know because they don't tell me what
to do i think brian's more of a silent
partner if he had a choice he'd probably
just not have to work here at all
this table
had a hair in their fries
i don't want to deal with this you deal
with it greg is the hardest working
owner but he doesn't make a decision who
the [ __ ] put these letters on here i
couldn't tell you
out of the three owners i like david
littles because his ego tends to get in
the way of a healthy atmosphere don't
touch the tickets please the main
problem with the black pearl is these
guys are really stubborn and if gordon
ramsay can help us all kind of mesh
together then this place can be
phenomenal
new york city one of the most difficult
places ever to open a wrestling i opened
mine 14 months ago and i've been busting
my balls ever since i'm dying to see how
the black pearl are doing
[Music]
right the black pearl there you go
hello
how are you doing good and you are nigel
nigel my name's steven steven how are
you
we here at the blackpool desperately
need gordon's help we need him to come
in and kind of whip all of the owners
into shape how's business it could be
better but with three owners and all
three have been over the business they
must be here one three four times a week
each together no they're never here
together no they're never here together
no
is that one of the owners yes it is
excellent
what's your name david leonard davis
gordon nice to see you
you are
one of the three owners one of the three
owners and are you hands on or hands off
hands hands on and how many days a week
are you here i do three or four three or
four okay good i'm gonna grab a quick
bite to eat maybe start off with a
little bowl of chowder and then maybe
have a chat after i'll be around when i
walked in and first met gordon i thought
he seemed a bit confrontational that was
not very pleasant
but otherwise i really had no impression
of him i'll be back with some water for
you hey my name's steven so if you need
anything just let me know thank you i
like your enthusiasm by the way thank
you
what a weird bar
and when you look at the bizarre
concoction of the interior
it does confirm that three different
people the owners of course decorated it
all right wow that was quick now how
many is in the kitchen how many people
yeah
three three there you go well thank you
that smells lily did you need more time
to look at the menu or just um no i'll
order now actually you know um i'll go
for a uh muscle bangkok all right a mac
and cheese lobster please and then i'll
finish with a lobster roll if you're
looking for the most popular one it
would be the main and the connecticut
bring me three of them all three all
right will do thank you so much
my name's steven so if anything just let
me know no you are just making sure if
you need anything just yell if
anything's bad i didn't do it though so
i don't want to know
what was your name michael no what your
name huh very funny
ah
you're a kidder
when chef ramsey jokes around with me i
think it added that personal spark of oh
you know chef ramsay isn't this evil
devil that everybody sees them as well
first
okay then the lobster mac and cheese
after that okay and he has a chowder
right now mmm
a little bit watery for a chatter huh
[Music]
hello chef how are you oh 51d thank you
are you muscles bangkok i'm greg what's
your owners oh what are the owners i'm
not chef trust me my food
come from nice to meet you nice to meet
you
so there's one more owner to come yes
brian so david brian and greg
okay great lovely refusing
thank you go ahead
burn your mouth off my god
[Music]
[ __ ] me it's hot
lobster mac and cheese accent lobster
mac and cheese wow
thank you
speak of the devil and i'll let you in
brian how are you nice to meet you i'm
good yourself yeah everyone thank you
yes
how did three of you come to run a
restaurant originally david and i had
the place uh down on evan away and then
we decided to get out of there
fascinating okay i'm gonna tuck into my
uh mac and cheese with lobster okay
thank you
it gets more complicated
i'm figuring we send out all three
lobster rolls on separate plates dressed
just like they would be yeah yeah yeah
so far he doesn't like much
what do you mean food wise the muscles
can't taste of muscles because they're
stupid
thai curry bangkok broth mac and cheese
it's chewy and rich and the chowder not
watery it's not how a seafood restaurant
should run this is not going to be a
good thing
[Laughter]
thank you all right this is the
connecticut or the hot lobster roll okay
this is the main lobster roll main
lobster whoops can i take your main
don't worry about that and this is the
new york city lobster roll new york city
yes connecticut maine gotcha already
that's great thank you all right let's
start off with ct
drawn better
horrible
soaking wet bread it's like eating a
[ __ ] wet diaper so sorry connecticut
but i am moving on
lobster's not seasoned
lamb
all right so what did you think of the
main
pretty piss-pool to be honest
i'm gonna stop there thank you stephen
what's up
well he likes stephen
yeah that's all i know that's his boy is
he still here yeah he's still upstairs
what's he doing he's eating he had three
lobster rolls three different kinds he
had mac and cheese he had um bangkok
david wants to know is he paying for
this you should definitely yeah give him
a check i can see that that'll be fun
huh
[Music]
after tasting the supposedly best food
on the menu how are you gordon gathers
the three owners and head chef phil who
oversees the food i do the award-winning
lobster roll bread soggy
lobster bland do you not season it salt
pepper when you bind it with mayonnaise
no no why not
well we get most of our recipes and
ideas from maine and it's not the way
it's done they have salt in maine i've
lived in maine for three months i know
it very well chef ramsay didn't like our
lobster roll and he said he's lived in
maine for three months but if he'd lived
in maine for three months he'd know that
a lobster roll is exactly the way we
make it i'm really nervous now i've
never known a chef that's not allowed to
seize his food is this man your chef or
is he your puppet
no he's my chef
david has this tone of being
condescending and
knowing it all how much debt have we got
over the house quarter
yeah
yeah
who has the final say if one of us
presents an idea we vote on it and we
decide whether we want to go forward
with it or not is it hard running a
business with three partners it's hard
for us yeah when was the last time all
three of you sat down we have not we
have not done so okay i don't feel
that any of you are committed to making
this work have you fallen out oh yeah a
couple of three times so that's why we
don't meet yeah okay who fell out with
who
i get mad at them why uh because i don't
think they're doing what they need to do
and we feel exactly the same about him
of course yeah
i felt that gordon was right about many
things but i think he jumped to
conclusions and that we are not
committed to black pearl
a restaurant run by three passionate
owners no chance brian he works two days
a week david wellm i don't trust him one
little inch and as for greg well he's
pissed off with both of them basically
in a nutshell sleepy dopey and grumpy
who am i it's no [ __ ] white
[Music]
after a frustrating conversation with
the owners chef ramsay decides to take a
look at how the black pearl operates
during a dinner service especially on a
night that all three owners are there
the chowder is good
that's really good i promise i'm
ordering two hot lobster rolls where's
that fisk phil call me right now david i
got a crab cake's getting cold two
lobster rolls and a fried shrimp to beef
uh the shrimp rolls aren't ready yet
what happened with that i don't have a
fried french fries
so when you and brian are here together
on the same day ryan takes care of that
we're never here together soon are you
never here
yeah it was weird having david in here
expedited because he doesn't normally do
that and having someone on this side of
the line that knows what they're doing
is key we have one more crab kick no no
you sold the last one ah that's it we
don't have it
oh my god that's cool
hey how are you guys doing
i believe this made me raw
what's up
undercooked underkilled that way we d
fat frying it this can't be normal
there's surely to show
i need an order of fried shrimp this one
was undercooked
david's lack of experience on the pass
is resulting in lack of quality control
they wanted these two well done zap them
i'm [ __ ] believing
what's that four [ __ ] ups already with
them i think it was a competition
amongst the three owners to try and
prove to chef ramsay that they knew what
they were doing and i felt greg kind of
felt out of his element because he's
normally in the kitchen i'll take this
back and we'll
do something about the muscle okay thank
you we got stand in the muscles they're
supposed to be santa's humor is that's
why they get a [ __ ] bra i don't know
guys so people don't know what the [ __ ]
they're ordering what are they ordering
david's definitely a know-it-all and
he can be a little rude what table is
that table eight thank you
hi you had the uh klembik
and there was a problem with the mussels
or the steamers
so they're terribly scented yeah there
should be sandals here there often is
and that's why you have the broth to dip
them in what would you like instead of
those uh nothing in fact i'll just eat
the lobster i'm fine okay it'll be right
out
i do not think that chef ramsay likes
david because
chef ramsay has a [ __ ] detector
and david could be full of it sometimes
what happened thanks chef no they're
done they're done yeah they just didn't
like it jesus christ
that's the funniest fish and chips i've
ever seen in my life you know
what happened
i just smell inside there will you
please phil
two seconds
this smells all right to me
from the thing
what do you smell phil it smells old
why didn't they eat it i don't know
gordon yeah do you ever ask yourself
that question i don't i ask myself that
question all the time i suppose you
actually don't give a [ __ ] you know that
i do give a [ __ ] and you know i give a
[ __ ] you seem a very relaxed man with
your what do you want me to do i
disagree it doesn't smell bad to me the
fish i've just given a piece of your
chef yeah the piece was stinking it
wasn't stinking you're blind my friend
no if you're not blind you're [ __ ]
clueless you know that
now the owner said it's not stinking
it's fragrant fresh and perfect that's
why it came back right
massage's ego
concerned about the quality control of
the food yeah
and the truthfulness of the owner gordon
wants to do a little investigating
they're all from maine these are uh
maine some from canada they look
canadian lobsters to me yeah these are
so the canadian lobsters are always a
lot cheaper i use the canadian lobsters
for raviolis and taglitellis and
spaghetti but they're not main lobsters
[Music]
after a disappointing dinner service
comes to an end gordon is ready to share
some of his initial observations tough
day today and i'm um
i'm deeply concerned
i see a ship here that is rudderless and
maybe that was the first time that all
three of you were working inside this
restaurant in a long time tonight showed
when was the last time you expedited all
the time i'm back there you were not
you're not really back there as much as
you were back there tonight no no never
because it's never been that we've never
had the whole lineup the whole line with
tickets ever david
can you stop being a slippery eel for 15
minutes in front of your team and answer
the [ __ ] truth gordon the [ __ ]
truth is that i'm back there when it's
busy every [ __ ] night that i work i
think a lot of what jeff ramsey's had to
say about david was fairly true i don't
believe that david shows that he cares
okay i've i've seen enough today i've
got to go and start really seriously
[ __ ] understanding you know how to
get a direction within this restaurant
i'll see you first thing in the morning
good night uh david yeah
you tell me about the passion with the
main lobster are you aware that the
lobsters in your fridge are canadian
same waters north atlantic waters
you're telling me now a canadian lobster
half a private main lobster is the same
taste and flavor
there's a big difference
i can't get maine lobsters that's right
so they get them from i'm using canadian
lunch that's right that's what they do
but i don't advertise them as maine
tell me is it a different animal
maine
is a canadian lobster for you i'm artis
americanus same animal right holy [ __ ]
i'm asking you a question
what you're trying to dictate to me is
that you're selling maine lobster
they're not from maine well it comes
from the same vendor
holy [ __ ]
the award-winning
maine lobster roll it's canadian
he was wrong about the lobster issues
it pissed me off i thought that was a
bit unfair for him to take that stand
and especially since he was incorrect
about it i'll see in the morning
good night
that was fun
incredible
it's a new day and gordon has organized
a staff meeting how are we good a rarity
here at black pearl as there have not
been any meetings in the last seven
months okay
a quick exercise so i want to find out
how you feel
we're going to write anonymous questions
when you write make sure you put the
name you want the question to at the top
of it fold it up and put it straight in
the pot
okay
greg how come you waffle with your
answers
basically i try to keep everybody happy
because otherwise i wouldn't have a
staff and that's why i sometimes waffle
and go back and forth but if you had a
little bit stricter philosophy
oh yeah i could definitely be stricter
thanks for being honest okay
david why haven't we got aprons
they know where the aprons are they just
don't choose to wear them but why can't
you say it's policy to be in an apron
cat it's policy for you not to have a
drink here after your shift but you
often do
why can't you ask my question without a
question i did answer your question
he did that is quintessential david
he'll answer you with the question so
to communicate with him can be very
frustrating david show the girl some
respect will you
you're great at beating around the bush
you know that
in front of everybody why can't you
answer the [ __ ] question
i thought i did answer the question
rather trying to be such a smart ass and
answer the question
do you know what i've just discovered
you're so full of [ __ ] [ __ ] you'd
make a great politician you know that
david has the biggest ego he's very
stubborn and obviously you're not doing
everything correct so get over yourself
and allow somebody to help you
incredible
i'm [ __ ] surprised you've got anybody
working for you
over the last half hour you'll look so
so cool as if you don't give a [ __ ]
it's disgusting
but finally to all three owners why
don't we have one general manager
what are they crying out for greg you
got for direction they need a rudder
make it one of the three why can't it be
just one of the three owners thank you
absolutely critical one voice one
direction
so who's committed
[Music]
i believe that i'm capable of doing it
uh but now i have to follow through and
do it i think brian and david will get
on board i'm going to get some pressure
[Music]
as the owners were contemplating which
one of them should be the hands-on
manager chef ramsay decided to generate
some excitement for tonight's dinner
service by adding a new special okay
yep
right time for a new beginning okay the
secret of this dish is the lobster
bernades lobster eat first underneath is
breadcrumbs potatoes and a hint of
rosemary first off the membrane and the
inside of the lobster
out we said this one open and out okay
done
and our potatoes
okay get the taste nice and crispy yeah
put our breadcrumbs in there two
thousand tater one third breadcrumbs
okay now they're starting to color okay
good out
and lightly fried okay line the shell
with that
now i want to see it ooze lobster okay
on and then we'll go with our sauce
absolutely delicious
and then in the salamander okay
this is a absolute pleasure to have him
in here and showing us things and we
learned a lot
lobster
i would pay 40 for that yes
right get some forks in let's have a
little taste a little bit of pecorino
lightly over the top it's delicious
[Music]
i'm not blowing smoke in my ass but that
was [ __ ] delicious this is great
[Music]
long day today
i want to try something for tonight so
here's what i'm going to do i want you
to run into place for an hour okay you
expedite and then you switch and i want
to see one person step up to the mark
and take control of the ship
unfortunately the appendix now all three
of you it's brian we don't need him he's
a nice guy and all that but nice guys
don't run restaurants okay all right
thank you
david's gonna be expedited for the first
hour and we're gonna switch back
if i have the choice of greg or david i
would definitely prefer greg because i
think he's a really nice person and
great to work with
what's up you get to go home
really yeah okay all right
am i out of here do you mind i i don't i
mean you don't mind that's great is it
all right
yeah absolutely fine don't take it
personally you can't have a relaxing
evening all right excellent it felt a
little uncomfortable being pulled from
my own restaurant but i get to go home
how much longer open open open up and
you're ready guys okay
hi there welcome to black pearl right
this way louise
all right you guys enjoy ready to rock
thank you very much
and roll
the specials for today um
are on the front flap it's a one and a
quarter pound lobster split in half and
then with the bernay sauce on top of
that it's delicious i have to say it was
really good
next time you come back would you bring
me a diet soda and mix a little bit of
club soda in it too that's not quite so
sweet
here let me get that out of your way you
want um these you wanna keep these or
take those away okay and don't just put
the club side at the end because then it
won't have the mixture
you know mix it in thank you take care
now good to meet you
[Music]
so i have two fish and chips table 36.
how about i rip your [ __ ] heart out
what when david's expediting orders
sometimes i'm a little
nervous about going into the kitchen to
ask about my tables because he'll just
bite back at you i i fired this one so
yep no that's why it's over there all
right
talk to me like i'm a real person not
like i'm an idiot
dude i just want to remind you um this
one i wrote gluten-free i got it we're
all simple
we have several brands in here oh my god
keep an eye i'm gonna go switch with
greg
switch okay
right we're halfway through service and
uh greg's on the hot plate now i can't
wait to see what happens but personally
once a waffler always a waffler we'll
find out
[Music]
muscles bangkok thank you
i can't find them bangkok thank god
there they are that it is you're coming
or going
coming
how many are you
five under what name
jackson david sometimes can uh patronize
the customers a little bit
traction five
i rather have someone that's gonna be a
cordial about it than some [ __ ]
that's gonna patronize everybody man you
guys are watching
phil this loves the role sitting here
what's it going with i didn't tell you
it was even ready
it's waiting for a roast for later talk
to you guys
that's what i'm trying to say i mean
just sat there [ __ ] going soggy
standards yeah let's start to talk to me
too i'm down here
[Music]
it's a blue point malpeke and a
melaspina and they said they already had
it they did they did then why am i doing
it again 35 and i have no clue you can
use greg we've got food backed up now
last load of defense which tables don't
like it well it was um my table eight
and two thirty did they fire it no okay
fire it they're waiting they already had
their oysters muscles with garlic
lobster bernays it seems to be slower on
the hot plate we dragged the helm then
when it's baby yes it does it seems to
be a little bit slower with craig
greg i feel
is trying his best
hey the fisk no
jesus christ where the hell did that go
why don't you call it so i know what it
is what are you waiting for die oysters
oh they're coming then all right maybe
where the hell did it go i don't have a
lobster bisque
it went out
come on get it together man
making another two
shit's [ __ ] getting very [ __ ]
tired getting very [ __ ] tired of that
[ __ ]
[Music]
just when things seemed completely out
of control i don't have a lobster bisque
where the hell does that go getting very
[ __ ] tired of that [ __ ] come on guys
greg settled things down in the kitchen
put the old girl on the plate and get
her out of here all right thank you sir
86 it and managed to get the final few
plates out that's it start cleaning out
breaking it up
before gordon can turn black pearl
around he needs to find one managing
owner so he gathers the staff to make a
decision
if all of you
had to choose
one
out of the three owners to direct and to
run this place completely who would it
be write it down for me
[Music]
okay
first person
david
second vote
greg
third vote greg
fourth vote
greg
and finally
greg
this is pretty significant you know that
guys how do you feel greg if you were to
run this place i'd run out the way i
think it should be run um i would do a
lot more with the staff um and i
wouldn't have to justify myself all the
[Music]
all three time
you
have fragmented this business david
isn't it best that we listen to the team
for that cry of help rather than having
to massage your own egos i think greg
would be a perfect general manager
david is full of [ __ ] i've heard him say
many times that greg has no idea what
he's doing in a restaurant so it will be
very interesting i'd definitely like to
give it a shot for sure
thank you all for being honest
thank you
well one thing's clear that the staff
want greg to run this place even david
wants greg to run it so that's good news
but i'm not 100 certain that greg has
the ball to run this place properly on
the back of tonight's performance but
what i can tell you is the business does
not leave ryan
in the city that never sleeps chef
ramsay's team worked all through the
night to transform the black pearl into
a manhattan hot spot
right good morning good morning you
ready yeah let's go
oh my god
everything is uniform wow much better
we haven't got three different sections
with three different colors
it's not a mix-and-match oh those are so
cute
it's vibrant classic and inviting like
it should be oh this is so nice
i
love the lobster right it gives us a
great boost this is a really a real good
shot at getting this thing up and moving
the way it needs to be
davey what do you think
columns should be yellow
everything's reorganized it's you know
it's another way to do it david
please don't touch it does it blow me
away no
i've got something to explain over here
something quite exciting
it was donated by the marine ecological
habitat now i promise you you'll never
find another machine anywhere like this
in new york and david
i promise you now between you and i
this is from maine
[Music]
of course if they catch it they eat it
yes
i think it's terrific
we're gonna have all sorts of people
coming in there trying to get a lobster
out of that
and people will be attracted to it you
were mine and it's gonna be a lot of fun
to watch
as the staff enjoyed the new interior
chef ramsay got set to reveal another
change it looks great happy everybody
yes yes
now
we have to market this place yes and i
can't do it without the help of our
special guest here he comes
that's right how you doing buddy
manhattan's favorite lobster right we're
going to hit
times square and get some noise on there
we're going to hand out flyers we're
going to hand out t-shirts we've gotta
shout it out okay louie the lobster i'll
see you in times square in five minutes
yes get going buddy yes and louie if you
[ __ ] up you're going in the tank okay
[Music]
[Applause]
being in times square with chef gordon
ramsay and all those people was a
terrific idea have a great day yes thank
you very much come here to your
restaurant tonight it's new york the
word spreads fast so i think people will
be rolling in tonight come visit us
going to times square with the lobster
guy and where all the tourists are and
tell them to come down and eat at your
restaurant
we're not going to see any effect from
that i'd be really surprised
[Music]
only hours before the doors open for
relaunch chef ramsay wants to get
everyone up to speed on the new menu
okay start off from the top uh we'll go
through each and every dish and then
we'll have a little taste after okay
okay good right two chowders yes
manhattan clam chowder new england clam
chowder yeah the lobster roll black
pearl uh special and it's gonna be
toasted on the inside as well okay so it
doesn't go soggy and there we go the
boston cream pie and a waffle sundae
it's fresh it's vibrant standards are
gonna be set tonight and the kitchen's
gonna be properly run okay good i'm
gonna get changed get some moving forks
start tasting
majorly trendy you taste the ceviche
this is so good not very good
i don't like it
those scallops were so good oh my god
this looks like heaven i like that
shrimp thing either oh it's amazing wow
and that's good too what kind of fish is
cod fish
i don't really like that
with relaunch night upon them gordon
gathers the owners to implement his
biggest change when you think back to
the beginning of the week it's been a
bit sort of tempestuous but we did come
to a consensus on who should be running
this restaurant
this is a document basically outlining
that all three of you are happy for greg
to be running the black pearl could you
just read it out for me we the partners
david leonard greg ryan and brian woods
agreed to name greg ryan as the managing
partner of the black crow at which time
decisions involving bigger issues arise
greg must call a meeting to present the
proposed changes to all the owners a
majority rule would determine whether or
not the proposed changes should be made
that's it
who'd like to sign first
my name's first
i'll sign first i don't know if i have
more faith than greg so if greg succeeds
that'll be great wonderful there you go
so you're now running this place i am
yeah good david brian tonight you're
coming as guest all right 6 30. tables
booked
i'll see you later beautiful thank you
now get the [ __ ] out of it i definitely
feel that i'm in control now um and then
i'm gonna run the business the way i
think the business needs to be run all
right guys we're gonna have a big night
tonight we have a beautiful new
restaurant we have a wonderful new menu
and we're gonna have a lot of people in
tonight and that's best thing that can
happen here anyway so please everybody
have a great time do a good job and
we're going to be great okay
thank you
[Music]
party of five buddy of five this weekend
make sure the waiters get the customers
up to have a little go of pulling the
lobsters out oh yeah yeah
yes i will ready and then we'll let you
have them
make sure make sure we get the customers
up play uh lobster rama
we are encouraging customers to try for
a lobster because if you catch one we
seam it for you and it's free
here we go first course new england clam
chowder field greens and tuna ceviche
it's gonna be a big night tonight and
this is greg's chance now to step up to
the mark and prove to him and he's two
partners that he's capable of running
this business we've got a flip table
it's going to be a lot of pressure and
more importantly the kitchen has a menu
streamlined they can push out quickly
only time will tell
real swordfish in a uh
and a burger and a burger medium and
medium rare and swordfish
what do i take where'd it go gordon
introduce you to my closest friends in
the world are you as stubborn as this
one uh yeah yeah
jordan i'm a guest oh sorry excuse me
yes welcome come in come out the cold
please
we're gonna host this over here please
as customers roll in the kitchen is
about to be slammed with orders and greg
and his kitchen staff are about to face
their first big test a chicken a slider
of bernays and a two fries also another
fish another burger medium you're
killing me chef to kill me the lanterns
those things are terrible this bishop
put candles three chickens for sword
thank you my table one
salad they got the table table one so
what do they want
instead of fries she wanted a salad i
have it
i first saw the tank part and i said we
got us a [ __ ] lobster tank the only
one in new york what does that tell you
what can we do anything
got a gun
what's the matter on table 27 i put in
the pearls an appetizer and i did not
fire their entrees yet and they're
getting their entrees oh [ __ ] come on
hold on v3 this is all beautiful p3
right here yeah that's what i'm trying
to do
service sucks here kitchen must be
[ __ ] buried
[Music]
i got grilled swordfish two soups two
seafood casseroles get cooked for two
people calling orders i don't give a
[ __ ] just make it son of a [ __ ]
i'll take this back and i'll see what we
can do about that all right
34 said he got him new england claims
give me a break i need a manhattan clan
i mean a new england clam chowder now
geez
tonight has been like a [ __ ]
again the kitchen got backed up it took
forever for all of our food to come out
come on greg we gotta run it we're
falling behind in there come on it's
ridiculous that lobster sellers we sat
down there for [ __ ] 20 minutes what's
going on yes you're supposed to go out
with this table right come on
the uh coleslaw very different from ours
we had a great coleslaw we had a great
coleslaw we can go back on that that's
ridiculous greg you told me 33 for the
fish and chips i did not tell you 33. i
didn't tell you anything oh my god you
got a pen i got to rent this down note
the greg our puppet dictator so she
wants a salad give her a salad just tell
me that ah
[Music]
medium rare
thank you where do you go what do you
need
[ __ ]
uh what does she want this medium for
the [ __ ] set what did you call it so
i know what i have called it i've called
it a dozen times i got grilled swordfish
two soups a sirloin burger two lobster
rolls
all right i need table twenty i need
table one i i mean table nine i got [ __ ]
getting cold it's been a chaotic evening
right there right there it's going out
the door right now and the kitchen has
been on the brink of disaster you guys
you gotta sell your kitchen too well he
can't do it all for you right but greg
has not given up get him organized and
neither has his staff
i need three of these right off the bat
just stack them up there i'm going to 36
i'll be back
excuse me who's the blueberry crumble
people
okay what's the feedback from the
champion everyone really likes the food
even though it's taken a while to get
there without having david or brian
around it was actually all right it was
pretty good the staff worked very well
together and so that made me feel good
all night long
the lobster is really good
nice and fluffy you might have to do
another waffle thing yeah i cut about
four more holes
all right we got one ticket left
greg's doing really good he's making
decisions like right and left and that's
a big change high fives guys
i just can't wait to see what's gonna
happen two three months from now after
chef ramsay is left
after a tough relaunch dinner gordon
gathers david brian and greg to give his
final words of advice tonight
you stood on that hot plate and you
busted your ass off
all night long mate you've got a big
heart
[ __ ] me have you got passion thank you
but
whilst you've got the hunger and the
passion i don't think your two partners
actually give a damn
you are an honest
individual you're here two days a week
but
you don't put the effort in
[Music]
you amaze me what because all week long
face to face
you [ __ ] pretend to care oh [ __ ]
gordon come on you don't give two [ __ ]
about this place really you're not
passionate about running a restaurant
really you're just abusing it and using
it what what what do i do i've never met
an individual that's so full of [ __ ] in
all my life how have i been lying to you
gordie how tell me gordon yeah how want
to just respect me i can disrespect you
too but tell me how tell me tell me i'm
not disrespecting you i'm telling you
the truth disrespect me because you
don't know the truth you're just
massaging your [ __ ] ego gordon
[ __ ] what do you mean [ __ ] not
true from the first minute you walked in
this [ __ ] door standing there with
your big long coat and your [ __ ]
sunglasses looking like proud [ __ ] that
was it first impressions
then you start debating lobsters because
you think you're some smart art on the
back of a few [ __ ] [ __ ] dive books
are you aware that the lobsters in your
fridge are canadian homartis americanus
same animal right humanness americanus
my arses
with 21 restaurants under my belt i work
my [ __ ] ass off so what so what i
never take anything for granted
fascinating you
treat the staff like [ __ ] you amaze me
never did that excuse me never
cat it's policy for you not to have a
drink here after your shift but you
often do
never
you can't even be honest
with yourself let alone me
mate you've been exposed oh yeah you're
a hypocrite is that right absolutely
yeah for you
it's about a [ __ ] tv show
this man is about a restaurant
[ __ ] the tv david
and i mean [ __ ] it
this is real for me
and for you it's an image
i disagree with you on almost everything
you said you do yeah i do why'd you
disagree because you're wrong
the great gordon ramsay is wrong
you're a sad [ __ ]
my advice is for him to get his partners
get your money out yeah and disappear
all right well my advice would be for
you to disappear and the sooner the
better
you don't get it do you
[ __ ] you gordon of course i get it this
question has every chance of succeeding
but not why you are in it
because
you're not passionate
you're soulless
say what you like let me get out of here
you're ungrateful
and you know what really hurts the
amount of effort has gone into it
despite what a prick you've been to me
i'm still grateful that you were here i
love what you've done i think that the
menu is brilliant
i like it i don't like it i don't really
like that i like that shrimp thing
either it's what happens when i've gone
we had a great call slot come back
we can go back on that that's ridiculous
the minute i'm out that door you'll slip
back into the
lazy ways why don't you come back in and
you know i'm sure you will and see how
it goes yeah
time will tell i guess it will
thanks again good
good night
goodbye good night
[Music]
that's tough i've been really tough and
personally i've got mixed feelings about
this week because i still want this to
succeed for greg because he's got the
determination the guts to make it work
but on the other hand david well i think
he's just opened a restaurant because he
wants to make a quick buck and that is
not the reason doper restaurant that man
has no passion tough